change is hard especially if you're an
outgoing u.s president coming to terms
with your so-called
legacy the transition of power those
weeks between the election in november
and the new president's inauguration
in january is a delicate process
in theory it requires a good working
relationship between the
incumbent and the newly elected
president who's headed for the white
house
the reality is very different though
look at donald trump for example it does
kind of look like he's trying to [ __ ]
up for the biden administration he's
blacklisting chinese companies in the
u.s before a china-friendlier
biden even takes office
and he's presided over a doj rule change
which will
effectively bring back firing squads and
electric chairs for the states that
can't get hold of the drugs
for lethal injections and yet he's
against abortions
unborn children have never had a
stronger
defender in the white house plus the
fact that trump has convinced
half of america that the election was
stolen from him means that we're not
likely to see
any uber awkward photos just like these
when barack obama had to grit his teeth
and welcome trump
into the white house in 2016. but
transitions
have always been tricky john adams and
thomas jefferson the founding fathers
and besties fell out so badly during the
course of the election
in 1800 that adams didn't even go
to jefferson's inauguration could happen
again the period of a presidential
transition is also a dangerous one
when it comes to foreign policy it's
unlikely that israel would have whacked
the iranian scientist allegedly without
trump's
tacit approval but we have some bad
hombres here perhaps in the hope of
provoking tehran
into doing something rash
both bb and donald are said to be
feeling a rising anxiety about the
impending arrival of the biden team who
are
keen to get the iranian nuclear deal
back from the deep freeze and loads of
historians have blamed the
disastrous bay of pigs fiasco in cuba
which took place in the first
three months of kennedy's presidency on
the grey area and the power vacuum
that happened as a result of the
presidential changeover
but there's awkward transitions and then
there's bill clinton
[Applause]
[Music]
bill's team's lack of largesse
shall we call it when handing over the
reigns to george w bush
after a bitterly contested legal fight
over the election in 2001 has become the
stuff
of legend clinton
[Music]
with the help of his brother and his
brothers-in-law
pardoned 140 people on his last day
in office wow including
worldwide pariah mark rich a cocaine
trafficking kingpin
oh yeah and his own brother roger
but even after that the clinton team did
not leave gracefully
[Music]
clinton staffers reportedly ripped
phones from the walls
cut presidential seals out of the
carpets
and left anti-bush graffiti in the men's
toilet stalls but
best of all they removed the letter w
from 62 of the white house's computers
let's learn about the letter w the
clinton team denied many of these claims
but the general accounting office
reported that the white house had
suffered
some fifteen thousand dollars worth of
damages
a third of that was spent on replacing
keyboards i'm sure there won't be any
pettiness
this time around